Taylor Swift is teasing us with cryptic
messages also jay-z breaks his silence
on Solange and the elevator and this is
all as captivating as it's a Clips thing
after you solar eclipse day as a
prophecy has foretold when the Sun turns
black Taylor Swift will emerge in the
form of a snake on Instagram leave it to
Taylor to overshadow a cosmic event am i
right the girl has been in hiding
keeping a low profile while she's
tinkering away at her next record and
she really sent fans into a frenzy on
Friday wiping her entire social media
history clean tweets gone Instagram post
God what is it all mean Taylor this
morning we got another clue a cryptic
10-second post of the tail into the
dragon is it a snake I don't know but
since then silence a lot of fans were
speculating that her long overdue sixth
album would be called Eclipse you know
to coincide with today's historic event
others believes you've got a new song
called timeless when this site register
and Taylor's name popped up today there
are so many other fan theories -
including this post from Ke$ha hinting
at a collaboration writing making a song
with a casual Grammy Award winning
secret person now she used 13 emojis
which is Taylor's favorite number I
gotta say I am loving these conspiracies
and like the rest of you I cannot wait
to see what Taylor does next but I'm
holding out for an epic moment at the
VMAs of Sunday where Taylor and Katy
Perry squash the beef on the stage do it
do it do it do it you know Katy just
posted a celeb cameo packed trailer for
her swish swish music video some see it
as a response to Taylor's bad blood but
talking today with Sirius XM's the
morning mashup Katy made it seem like
AVM a duet with Taylor is unlikely all I
got to say they are missing out on a
moment then if they don't do it take a
cue from Britney Spears people nearly
everyone of Britney's VMA appearances
have been so frigging iconic and let's
keep it real she did the snake thing
first and Britney is still giving us
something to talk about
literally on Saturday night Britt gave
the haters
a piece of her mind at her piece of me
residency in Vegas addressing ghosts who
claims she doesn't sing live by covering
Bonnie Raitt's 1991 hit without a
backing track decide to the media of my
home I know it's really signages one
minute they tear you down they're really
horrible into the next minute you're on
top of the world
[Music]
classic Britney to use some cheeky humor
to get her point across I gotta say it
works like a charm but you know cute
covering country isn't she
you could take the girl out of Louisiana
but you can't take the Louisiana out of
the girl
all right meanwhile jay-z is speaking
out about that infamous elevator fight
with sister-in-law Solange that 2014
elevator bra after the Met Gala will not
only be a day that will live in infamy
it's a friggin unsolved mystery and
while we may never truly know what
caused it now in a rare interview Jay
tells rap radar the two have one
daughter like how did you and Solange
get to a better place we also happen in
a little bit of private moment but how
did that happen yeah I mean that I mean
I guess we've always had a great
relationship but you know I mean I
thought I put my brothers and like argue
my brother in my whole life you know
saying just so happened to who we are
these things go into a different space
but it ain't nothing we never had one
disagreement ever before and after we've
been cool you know it's like my sister I
would I would protect her I would you
know my sister now my my sister-in-law
not my know my sister right serious side
note but did you see there's an eclipse
on the back of that interview just
saying also you guys you know Jay is
really spilling the tea in this one he
even addressed the recent beef with
Kanye West after Kanye unleashed a
onstage rant about jay-z last year
Jay says he was hurt but what really
became a problem was that Kanye brought
up his family including his daughter
drew idea you don't put out kids in that
space like don't talk about anyone's kid
on stage you know there's too much
energy too much people and you just a
room for anybody to comment
I'll kill our children already are in
this place of where they are affected by
our celebrity don't go doing something
that now people to pit us against each
other and talk about my child talk about
history even child like you know don't
don't do that
second side note the just meters jay-z
getting kind of old
we're all well you went on to say
that the two have never left this much
space go between one of their
disagreements and while he appears to
name-drop Kanye and his song killed
jay-z
he's quick to explain that it's not a
disc he's talking about himself what do
you guys think it's a throne gone
forever
also which celeb feud are you the most
entangled with Taylor and Katie's or
Kanye and jay-z let me know I want to
talk about it alright but before we sign
off sins were filling Erie with the
Eclipse today I leave you with this
exclusive chat with Hollywood medium
Tyler Henry Tyler tells our Katie Kraus
about the intense season 2 finale of his
a show where notorious b.i.g comes
through in a reading with little camp
you got to check this out
biggie came through as a former lover he
came through very strongly in
acknowledging that he wanted her to know
that they were soul mates and how much
he loved her and he acknowledged their
relationship how their last interaction
was and discussed them the dynamics
behind that and it gave her a lot of
closure inhaling if she didn't obviously
to the nature of the fact it's like
coming through so strongly is like full
my full my soul mate so me so like we
need me with I just have done that how
emotional was she and what questions did
she have you know she was surprisingly
emotional I think she if she really was
a lot to take in I think she was
definitely overwhelmed and she just
wanted to know that he was at peace and
that he was aware of what she was doing
to honor his legacy mmm all right that
is it for us today check back tomorrow
for a new episode of The Daily Deni and
as always like comment and share this
video
plus we've got a lot to discuss in the
comments section so I will see you guys
there and until tomorrow goodbye